Today I'm going to show you 4 cool tricks
That you can practice at home!
This first one hasn't really got
anything to do with table tennis
But it's a cool party trick
And all you need
is one table tennis ball
The idea is to create a trap of air
Between your hands
So when you hit it
The ball will pop out
And it makes a cool sound
This one is actually not that difficult
if you know the technique
So the first step is to wrap your fingers around the ball
So no air can slip through
Once you have found the grip
You create a cup
with the rest of your fingers
The most important thing is not to squeeze the ball hard
It just has to be really gently on top
- just so it covers everything
Otherwise it won't come off when you hit
But if it's gently there
It comes off
Another thing is you don't hit it with your hand
The hand isn't hitting the ball in the air
- it's the pressure that pops it out
So all you need is a gentle tap
if you have the right grip
So this next one is actually quite good
practice for ball control
The idea is to roll the ball onto the
other side of the racket without the ball bouncing
And of course if you're a
beginner there's a lot of easier variations
If you want to start off with
these
Basically anything you do with the racket and the ball
Is good practice for control
So you can come up with whatever variations you want
Okay so this one won't make you
a better table tennis player
But
It makes you into a
cooler table tennis player
So all it is
is just one spin on your finger
And to do this
You give speed with your wrist
And just spin it over
And catch with your thumb
It's also important to spin it counterclockwise
because if you spin it clockwise
It's a lot harder to catch
Yeah, no. Doesn't work.
So you spin it this way
And if you want to take it further you can do the double spin
Triple spin
It's maybe best to practice this on top of something soft
Maybe this isn't so useless after all
You could come up with a...
cool serve to
fool your opponent or something
Or maybe not.
This one is quite hard to do
But if you can generate spin
It's not that hard to catch it with your nails
If you want to practice putting
spin on the ball
You can do it for example on the table
Just get below the ball
And hit it to the side
This is also really good practice for
controlling the ball
And understanding how spin works
So with your nails you form
a sort of circle
You don't even need to use all five fingers
I use four because it just feels more natural
After that all you need to do
is to catch it on your nails
If you want to put even more spin on the ball
You can throw the ball at the racket
And then catch it
This is also a pretty
useful way to check if the ball is round
Because if the ball is round
It's not gonna wobble
It's gonna have a smooth spin
And also you can hear it from
the sound
So for example this ball is really bad
It wobbles
And this one is good
It's a clean spin
So hope you guys learnt something
And got some fun ideas
to practice
Until next time!
Triple spin
So close!
1, 2, 3!